era ese gatito otra vez.
Todo esto fue posible
gracias a que pudimos encontrar la forma
de traducir un problema muy difícil
en algo que nuestros cerebros hacen con mucha naturalidad.
¿Qué quiere decir esto?
Bueno, para los gatitos significa
ya no esconderse entre los unos y ceros.
Para mí, significa ya no desperdiciar más fines de semana.
Para la ciberseguridad significa que tenemos una nueva forma radical
de abordar los problemas imposibles.
Significa que tenemos una nueva arma
en el teatro cambiante de la ciberguerra,
pero para todos,
significa que los ciberingenieros
ahora pueden ser los primeros en responder
en situaciones de emergencia.
Cuando los segundos cuentan,
hemos desatado los medios para detener a los malos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)